de notre point de vue il ne faut pas
démolir il ne faut plus démolir il faut
au contraire réhabiliter et l'énergie
est un sujet absolument
crucial aujourd'hui donc réhabiliter
isolée isoler les combles en premier
isoler les murs avant de penser
peut-être à changer son chauffage aussi
pour être sûr de pas se faire avoir par
des entreprises du bâtiment parce que il
y a un peu tout il faut savoir faire le
tri donc c'est notre travail en amont
pour être sûr d'avoir des vraies
personnes qualifiées compétentes dans
leur domaine
[Musique]
un gain de 40 à 50% au niveau de au
niveau du chauffage au niveau de tout ce
qui est perte de chauffage voilà 50% à
peu près on perd de l'énergie au niveau
des façades au niveau des toitures au
niveau des fenêtres voilà et nous nous
sommes spécialisés sur la façade
[Musique]
déjà le service public France Renov
c'est une aide en soi c'est un conseil
qui est gratuit et puis après il existe
aujourd'hui deux gros dispositifs d'aide
principaux c'est l'aide d'appeler ma
prime rénov qui a une prime énergétique
et puis ce qu'on financement apporté en
complément de cette prime par des
certificats d'économie d'énergie qu'une
contribution des gros pollueurs à la
rénovation FCA
[Musique]
IDF1 et idf3 viennent de conclure un
partenariat avec STO qui est numéro un
mondial de l'isolation thermique une
gamme beaucoup plus écologique mieux sur
ces
à base de de résine de pin
qui sera je pense un peu plus cher mais
beaucoup plus écologique
[Musique]